hey guys mkbhd here back with another
high definition video and today we're
going to be taking a look at the
blackberry playbook and today in fact
we're looking at the playbooks ad put
out by blackberry not too long ago now
the fact that it is an advertisement may
put some of you guys off but it is very
very telling and a lot of the things
about the playbook first thing i'll tell
you is that it does have a one gigahertz
dual core processor a seven inch screen
and does have a 1080p three megapixel
video camera on the back and a front
facing high definition video camera on
the front
a lot of the things you'll see here in
this commercial have nothing to do with
the tablet itself but the animations are
very reminiscent of something we've seen
in the galaxy tab or the ipad
this is because it's running rim's
latest version of the blackberry tablet
interface good call ram
also rim selecting to have their own
operating system dedicated to this
tablet means they're opening up also to
developers to develop applications for
this tablet so we'll go over that in a
second
something you'll see showcased a lot
here in this ad is that it's very
business driven because of the ability
to multitask you can run multiple
applications at once and that'll surely
be enhanced by the one gig of ram and
the dual core mobile processor it has
inside of it so you see a lot of these
animations are really smooth you'll see
flash content as it is flash loving and
you'll see a whole lot of other things
on that high resolution screen that you
wouldn't typically see on something like
the ipad or the smaller galaxy tab
it also appears that you'll be able to
pair your current blackberry phone with
the blackberry tab which makes sense as
things like that are already going on
with ios devices and with android
here at the end of the commercial we get
a really nice 360 view of the tablet and
a whole bunch of things rem is
showcasing including the camera position
there on the back you can see it offers
an uncompromised browsing experience
that is enterprise ready with rem's
tablet os and that they're advertising
it as a professional tablet looks to be
a really nice competitor to the other
tablets out there it'll be a great
addition to the tablet market and it
will nice be it'll be nice to see you
know how they price this and what it'll
really bring to the market in the future
so this has been mkbhd with a quick look
at the blackberry playbook as shown by
rim thanks for watching this video and
we'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace